all right listen I have absolutely no
problem criticizing someone I normally
praise or praising someone I normally
criticize broken clocks can sometimes be
right functioning clocks sometimes run
out of battery and give you the wrong
time of day so the point is we evaluate
each thing individually and last night
Tulsi gabbard former Democrat Tulsi
gabbard no longer a Democrat who Now
supported like Herschel Walker and
looked the worst of the worst Carrie
Lake Etc in 2022 she filled in for Fox
News propaganda's Tucker Carlson last
night and she interviewed habitual liar
republican-elect George Santos and I
have to tell you she really did a pretty
damn good job and I my earpiece is
flying out and I want to be able to hear
this so let me tuck it back in uh neatly
there
she actually does a good job of calling
it what it is take a listen to Tulsi and
George Santos the results that people
are looking for are called into
tell blatant and he increasingly gets
flustered which is great embellishments
and this is this is I think one of the
biggest concerns Congressman elect is
that you
really seem to be
to be apologized he's made mistakes but
you've outright lie a lie is not an
embellishment on a resume you said you
worked at Goldman Sachs and Citigroup
but they've said we've got no record of
this guy working for us you've said
you've gone to and graduated from these
universities but they've said well we've
got no record of that these are blatant
lies and it calls into question how your
constituents and the American people can
believe anything that you may say when
you are standing on the floor of the
House of Representatives now this is a
question
supposedly fighting for them that's the
real issue here
well look I and I I agree with what
you're saying and as I stated and I
continue
we can debate my my resume and how I
work you really it's not really for
debate though with firms such as is it
debatable or is it just false
yes
no no it's not false at all it's it's
debatable like it's totally false I want
to explain to you what you can do in
private equity in in capital intro via
servicing limited partners and general
partners and we can have this discussion
that's going to go way above the
American people's head yeah it would be
too complicated for the American people
for me to explain why it's not really a
lie for me to say I worked for Goldman
when I didn't because I worked for a
company that had Goldman as a client and
Well why'd you put Goldman on your
resume then it's not what I campaigned
on I campaigned on delivering results
for the American people but by lowering
inflation I can sit down if you want to
have that discussion I'd be glad to
Tulsi to explain that to you and make
sure that we we settled the score
that this is not about settling scores
and I think you just you just kind of
highlighted I think my concern the
concern that people at home have you're
saying that this discussion will go way
above the heads of the American people
basically insulting their intelligence
so not only are you now that's not what
I'm saying that you've told that's
exactly what he's saying but but you're
saying that you can't it's not waiting
in a way that your constituents would
actually be able to I can explain it in
a way to give me the time I can easily
give the if you give me the time I can
easily explain it for you as as in when
investors are looking for Capital and
I'm sitting there doing due diligence on
the on the appetite and what they're
looking at if this is all to explain why
he claimed to work at Goldman Sachs when
he did not when tool sees not buying
your lies you know you're digging pretty
deep here here's another clip from this
interview and again to tulsi's credit
she confronted him and he got
increasingly flustered because he should
because he's lying
so I can deliver for the American people
the thing is congressman-elect uh
integrity means yes carrying yourself
with honor but it means it means telling
the truth being a person of integrity
and if I were one of those in New York's
Third District right now now that the
election is over and I'm finding out all
of these lies that you've told not just
one little lie or one little
embellishment these are blatant lies my
question is do you have no shame do you
have no shame in the people who are now
you are asking to trust you to go and be
their voice for them their families and
their kids in Washington
Tulsi I can say the same thing about the
Democrats and and the party look at your
mind but don't the Democrats have shame
but we're not talking about them we're
talking about you claiming that you were
Jewish when you weren't applying to the
American people for 40 years he's the
president of the United States Democrats
but Biden once lied who resoundly
support him do they have no shame
because look this is made this very this
is not this is not about the Democratic
party though this is about your
relationship frankly with the people
who've entrusted you to go and and fight
for them and I think one of the
questions that that really probably by
the way asking whether he has shame as
she sits in Tucker Carlson's chair is
pretty rich but this is not about Tulsi
it's home to a lot of people is is are
you Jewish we've got a letter that your
campaign sent out earlier this year
which reads as follows as a proud
American Jew I've been to Israel
numerous times for educational business
and leisurely trips you said there in
that letter that you are quote a proud
American Jew how do you how do you
explain that
my Heritage is Jewish I've always
identified as Jewish I was raised a
practice he just said in the other other
interview I played for you that he has
always identified as Catholic but here
he says I've always identified as Jewish
in Catholic I think I've gone through
this even I've not not being raised to
practicing Jew I've always joked with
friends and circles even with in the
campaign I'd say guys I'm Jewish
remember I was raised Catholic so look I
understand everybody man Tulsi is just
not buying it so good job by Tulsi I
have no problem praising her even though
I think most of her contributions to
American politics are quite negative uh
and Santos is just so dishonest in the
earlier interview he says no no no
listen I've always said I'm Catholic
here he says no no no no I've always
identified as Jewish but I'm also kind
of Catholic and this and that and I'm
Jewish and there's a hyphen guys there's
a hyphen
The Hyphen makes all the difference in
the world this guy should resign
I hope that Republicans say you can't
stay dude you gotta go we will follow it
and let you know make sure you were
subscribed to the YouTube channel over 3
million different people watched Clips
in November and didn't subscribe if we
can just get a fraction of those folks
to hit the Subscribe button on YouTube
will be at 2 million subscribers before
you know it quick break and we'll be
right back
You Love non-fiction books you love
learning as much as you can about
politics and economics and history and
science but you just don't have the time
to read every book that you want to read
that's why I'm such a big fan of
blinkist it's the app that takes
thousands of non-fiction books boils
them down into an explainer that you can
read or listen to in 15 minutes and get
the most important insights from the
book you take a topic you've been
wanting to explore and you can consume
10 books about it in an afternoon it
gives you a meaningful overview and
insight into what other books you might
want to read in full I just read welcome
to the universe it's Neil deGrasse
Tyson's latest book that's exactly the
type of book that I would love to have
the time to read but my stack of books
is already so big my girlfriend and I
also use the blinkist connect feature to
share and discuss books with one another
with one account and it makes a great
late last minute holiday gift you can
try blinkist free for seven days and get
25 off a subscription at blinkist.com
packman the link is down below